dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here this is a
collaboration between deep mind and open
a eye on using human demonstrations to
teach an AI to play games really well
the basis of this work is reinforcement
learning which is about choosing a set
of actions in an environment to maximize
a score for some games this score is
typically provided by the game itself
but in more complex games for instance
once that require exploration this score
is not too useful to train an AI in this
project the key idea is to use human
demonstrations to teach an AI how to
succeed this means that we can sit down
play the game show the footage to the AI
and hope that it learns something useful
from it now the most trivial
implementation of this would be to
imitate the footage too closely or in
other words simply redo what the human
has done that would be a trivial
endeavor and it is the most common way
of misunderstanding what is happening
here so I will emphasize that this is
not the case just imitating what the
human player does would not be very
useful because one it puts too much
burden on the humans that's not what we
want and number two the AI could not be
significantly better than the human
demonstrator and that's also not what we
want in fact if we have a look at the
paper the first figure shows us right
away how badly a simpler imitation
program performs that's not what this
algorithm is doing what it does instead
is that it looks at the footage as the
human plays the game and tries to guess
what they were trying to accomplish then
we can tell a reinforcement learner that
this is now our reward function and it
should train to become better at that as
you see here it can play an exploration
heavy game such as Atari hero and in the
footage above you see the rewards over
time the higher the better this AI
performs really well in this game and
significantly outperforms reinforcement
learner agents trained from scratch on
montezuma's revenge as well although it
can still get stuck on
we discussed earlier a curious AI that
was quickly getting bored by ladders and
moved on to more exciting endeavors in
the game the performance of the new
agent seems roughly equivalent to an
agent trained from scratch in the game
punk presumably because of the lack of
exploration and the fact that it is very
easy to understand how to score points
in this game but wait in the previous
episode we just talked about an
algorithm where we didn't even need to
play we could just sit in our favorite
armchair and direct the algorithm so why
play well just providing feedback is
clearly very convenient but as we can
only specify what we liked and what we
didn't like it is not very efficient
with the human demonstrations here we
can immediately show the AI what we are
looking for and as it is able to learn
the principles and then improve further
and eventually become better than the
human demonstrator this work provides a
highly desirable alternative to already
existing techniques loving it if you
have a look at the paper you will also
see how the author's incorporated a cool
additional step to the pipeline where we
can add annotations to the training
footage so make sure to have a look also
if you feel that a bunch of these AI
videos a month are worth a dollar please
consider supporting us at patreon.com
slash two minute papers you can also
pick up cool perks like getting early
access to all of these episodes or
getting your name immortalized in the
video description we also support
cryptocurrencies and one-time payments
the links and additional information to
all of these are available in the video
description with your support we can
make better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time